is he like for you one of like the guys
that you most wanted to work with he was
he was my dream I'm the devil and I'm
here to do the devil's business at about
I think I saw Pulp Fiction when I was
about 11 or 12. really it was very yeah
young for that film no supervision at
home no no and and I started acting when
I was about 12 and and so we'd drive up
to La we're going to Nickelodeon
auditions or something and I became
obsessed it was the first time that I
remember thinking this is a great
screenplay you know I'd always seen a
film as a whole thing but then I sort of
was able to break it down and go
somebody had to write these words and
this is brilliant so I printed out the
script and I'd read it to my mom when we
drove up to auditions or acting class or
that sort of thing and so it would be
like somebody would pull up and I'd be a
12 year old kid saying to his mom you
know for five long years I carried this
watch up my ass
um and uh
five long years he wore this watch up
his ass